donc c'est les coulisses de tmp vu par
vos yeux jean luc way j'achète et c'est
tout lui s'arrête toujours à une
question
une question que voici bonjour je
m'appelle à la dans votre rubrique en
voit souvent jean-michel se moquer des
chanteurs qui vient de se produire sur
votre plateau donc je voulais savoir
pour qui se prend ce pays que je crois
qu'il a été candidat dans des jeux
fiennes seniors on l'a rencontré dans la
rue par un jeune majeur avec la combat
de tomber sur un plan qu'une dernière
alors je comprends votre énervement cher
à lomé et sachez que si jean michel se
permet de critiquer des chanteurs c'est
parce que lui même est de la partie bah
oui exactement
on connaissait l'ancien reporter de
guerre 1 le crac immédiat craint par
toute la profession salue vertige parti
trop tôt le nouveau sniper officielle
mais on ne savait pas tout jean michel
est insatiable c'est une machine
personne ne peut l'arrêter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé des pnp jamais conseille
de venir les plus grands jurys du
maintien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils se trouvent
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]
je
allez quoi jeu
il a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses séquelles que ce qui casse les
agressions musicale pendant les pubs
certains membres du public ont déposé
une main courante
jean-michel ya cette chaussée glissante
au milieu de ce que l'équipe mais c'est
ça qui est dommage mais je sais pourquoi
je n'ai jamais songé à capella
je pense que vaut mieux a cappella parce
que ça doit être vrai si votre voix la
chanson préférée votre les mots m'a
rendu accro mais j'aime ça non je me
voyais déjà
à l'avenir dans ses bras
il a bel et au rendu accro je ne savais
pas
je ne connaissais pas
bien entendu le timide j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'on va faire de jean
michel qui va bientôt participer à the
voice mise et très choqué pour la
première fois la soirée debout sur le
sujet c'est que jean richard n'est pas
le seul à pousser la chansonnette dans
l'équipe il ya aussi mathieu est très
bien johnny hallyday est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire donné l'idée et oui
mais ces données mais c'est ce à quoi la
mecque mathieu effet très bien johnny
qui parle barreau me suis pas chanteur
par contre quand il chante passé c'est
johnny en version plus bas c'est un
mélange entre johnny hallyday patrick
juvet c'est johnny je vais
ap
info
vous
tout le monde
ok
selon k
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et comment ceci vous connais bien la
balle et johnny pourri par les lords ya
deux hypothèses soit je limite mal quand
je chante soit en ligne aurait et johnny
était peut-être aussi avec le côté aussi
d'être féminin était très sensible aussi
on sait pas non mais c'est pas une
question de sensibilité c'est juste
avoir la voie qu'il faut c'est être
parce que simon shaw que j'avais aussi
la voix de johnny quand je chante fait
je serais pas au chroniqueur à côté de
toi je stresse stars internationales et
je rêvais il serait bien que tu as qui
fouillait ce qu'on la voit qu'il faut
c'est toujours juste à côté et ça tient
ça de ma carrière
tu truc bel organe comme vous le savez
bientôt une bonne partie mais qui va
partir ou en laponie
car ils petit scoop cyril à aimerait
qu'à la rentrée de janvier le père noël
soit chroniqueur pour savoir ce qu'ils
pensent de the voice pareils alors
petite interro surprise
est ce que vous connaissez la durée du
voyage entre la france et la laponie
9h45 non moi à 5 heures avec une escale
trois heures plus de trois heures et
demie environ
j'ai vérifié parce que kelly a mis un
gros doute faut dire que niveau logique
je sais pas si un prix nobel mais si oui
je pense que kelly peut le ramener
mais c'est passé combien de jours
[Musique]
ces gamins sans but là
on adore l aragon situé comme ça c'est
plus par delà et tu t'es le tour chaque
fois tu fais un tour d'un ter lille un
peu plus d'un jour de passé en suède
juste au dessus c'est simple au dessus
mais exactement vous saviez pas kiki
qualifié pour la laponie pour l'instant
mais vous allez bien vous amuser tous
les deux elle réfléchit trop élevés une
qui la préoccupe en ce moment je vais
vous dire la vérité
c'est daniel moreau ah oui vous
l'intrigué beaucoup enfin vous vous
l'intrigué depuis qu'elle a réalisé
quelque chose
[Musique]
chacun savait s'amuser
[Rires]
[Musique]
la voie de la ccc légaux mathieu chez
vous chaque jour mais non je devrais
plutôt chic au contraire celle qui
défend bien la fatwa qui liront doute
bien que la mère de kelly s'est pas
daniel quoi pourquoi vous qui vous
battez contre les idées reçues et les
stéréotypes les raccourcis mais tu
lances et quand je me fou dingue
[Rires]
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une tension
avec daniel on se demande tous quand ça
va se passer
a priori ce soir mais à quel moment le
petit chaperon moreau va rencontrer le
loup parce que ça donne du mal non plus
non on sent vous est au taquet oui vous
en parlait beaucoup
donc j'étais obligé de faire une
deuxième épisode de vos aventures et on
commence par sa déception à daniel
d'avoir perdu un jeu où l'équipe adverse
avait besoin avant elle c'est comme dans
la vie on s'est tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
kim est connu
je soutiens votre photo à 10 photo annie
c'est beau lui des mois lunaires
[Musique]
non mais désolé mais sexuelle humains
physiquement c'est quand même moi les
russes réclament gilles est ce que
daniel aurait pas être ton style ah oui
dans un autre monde
pourtant je vais courageuse à venir par
passer alors c'est la suite de cet
extrait entre daniel et gilles vous
allez voir jean-michel de faire une
vanne sur la vanne de cyril et ça va pas
passer du tout grand moment de solitude
non mais drm et sexuellement
physiquement c'est quand même plus
réclame pas attendez vous à regarder si
vous faites un enfant j'en veux 6
les corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce qu'à ce moment vous m'avez
descendu toute l'année dernière disons
que vous étiez le sniper officiel
concurrence donc du coup ça me dé moitié
sa dette et bien des motifs mais son
expérience a fait une très bonne
condition pour le top gênante
compilation des petits moments bizarres
de tmp un truc est sûr et certain rôle
scoop sortira d'ici
même la chaîne n'est pas au courant donc
y avoir des appels de la chaîne même la
chaîne n'est pas au courant je vais le
ballon c'est là les scieries on n'a pas
grand sens
[Musique]
c'est ou la prochaine
c'est quand même un jeune homme on y va
ensemble
m
[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être là et on te paie
mais aussi on s'embrasse you baby dont
je parle et parle pas comme ça ma femme
tu es gentille mamie
c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il s'appelle lui
[Musique]
jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
c'est le shérif de daniel aussi en
sécurité dans le monde merci à elles
mêmes
je l'avais vu dans ce vote j'ai craqué
on est devenu bon camarade mort ce soir
là j'ai vraiment grippe est là parce que
j'aurais mis le grappin dessus
ça lui a fait du bien ce mec est
chanceux quoi y en a un petit peu plus
non pas du tout dans ce soir ça va pas
être un peu sous la même et je voudrais
remercier un ami jean michel maire qui
répond toujours présent quand je fais
appel à lui
d'ailleurs alors on va profiter de
l'absence de syrie pour parler à coeur
ouvert
qu'est ce qui vous donne envie de venir
chaque vendredi mais qu'est ce que vous
aimez dans ce programme mais la bonne
humeur voilà la joie de vivre l'amitié
d'accord enfin je vous demande mais je
fais tout courant quand je suis tombé
sur cette conversation entre vous et
valérie bénaïm super perf et la semaine
est pourquoi il fallait y participer non
vous vous en souvenez ou pas expurgés
macalou du mont saint michel
j'ai des images ça nous est réclamée la
birmanie
[Musique]
si l'on regarde les images des loutres
il faut être sympa
[Musique]
vous pouvez prêter
[Applaudissements]
mes frères ce que j'aime bien c'est le
petit temps en fait après sept ans de
rubriques ne soit pas compris que même
quand tu chopes j'attends ton semaine
écoutez moi je vais vous dire je suis
très content on vous soyez là les
associations qui se forme par exemple
justine et mathieu à vous êtes bien
trouver tous les deux un
vous connaissez huguette et raymond dans
scènes de ménages manon à juju et va
tout
j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu pas que je suis chroniqueur
vrai couple messieurs samax bien mais
j'ai tout de suite dans ces quartiers
ses voix en or déstockage fendre la
foule
ouais foutu pour foutu baby cool pour
tout comme ça brison tout c'est quoi ton
prénom - murray quand on n'a jamais su
bon il y en a un peu plus même
eh ben on commence par vous on commence
à jouer à tout le monde mais on commence
par mathieu qui a priori n'est pas
spécialement fan de vita ou sinon il est
très pudique
[Musique]
l'artiste féminine la plus jouée en
radio en 2018
on exploite leur détresse
moi je vais vous dire j'en étais
liberato des dizaines alors il ya des
trucs qui m'interpelle mais si vous
allez en espagne fait attention
visiblement la bassée courante se battre
avec une pelle à tarte et deuxièmement
vous allez voir que le prof pour la
démonstration est ce qui est des âmes
romantiques autour de la taille je suis
marié
ayem ces tumeurs casse une forme
patauger m'énerver un an bientôt des
phrases gentil ok on va accueillir celui
qui est comme mon frère
quelle famille et on a en exclusivité un
contrat s'il est là à le contrat voilà
voyage c'est pas celui d'un noir il en
avait pas lui même un petit alors
contrôler les gens j'aime pas
c'est la concurrence regardez c'est
qu'ils jouent c'est grave
[Musique]
et
m
c'est vraiment cinq ans
salut je souhaite vraiment terminé
après les autres
g
[Musique]
ajouter quelque chose vous maintenez
cette affirmation ou aborder un bel
hommage ce soir on a fait ce qu'on
pouvait servir